et bonjour bonjour
Quelqu'un bonjour
bonjour
j'ai un peu de temps je
[Musique]
jusqu'à 2 mètres de haut c'est l'une des
plus grandes déodorants de fleurs du
monde qui est sur le point d'éclore au
jardin botanique de Nancy offrande
visiteur une vue et pousse soufflante la
floraison de l'arôme Titan autrement
appelé phallus de Titan a lieu que tous
les quatre ans et ne dure que 72 heures
environ la règle du jeu est très simple
le lanceur lance l'artichaut à 11 mètres
de là le receveur tant de le récupérer
dans sa haute le duo qui en compte le
plus en une minute et champion et c'est
physique des deux côtés
il faut réceptionner aussi et
quand tu as 15 ou 6 artichauts dans la
dans la haute c'est compliqué enfin ça
fait 30 kg dans le dos et il faut bouger
avec
reculer avancer c'est compliqué c'est la
plus grande inflorescence du monde
elle fait déjà presque deux mètres elle
a un tubercule de 33 kg et donc là dans
les prochains jours et bien vous allez
avoir l'épanouissement de cette énorme
inflorescence c'est un événement qui
arrive très très rarement en France
c'est seulement la cinquième floraison
et l'inflorescence qu'on a là c'est la
plus grande qui est jamais eu en France
puisqu'elle va dépasser 2 mètres
qui a dégagéabonde de viande dans
décomposition puis il vaut aussi des
surnom de fleurs de cadavre à admirer de
loin
on fait les câlins
mettez les capotes
pas d'enfant allez bonne soirée
elle a coupé elle a coupé le truc là je
crois
pour acquérir force et grâce le sport
féminin qui fut en France si longtemps
dédaigner doit être mis à sa vraie place
à la base même de l'éducation de la
jeune fille de la future mère de famille
française ce mot d'ordre a été illustré
par les Journées de la sportive qui
débutèrent par les épreuves nautiques
on t'a dit que tu ressemblais à
Anne-Isabelle Adjani on a souvent dit
[Rires]
gros fruit d'été ou grosse tête de
prétention melon oui
[Rires]
je vois pas le les points communs
pénaliser l'orthographe dans les copies
du bac pour certains ça rappelle de
mauvais souvenirs moi je sais que
j'avais certains profs qui enlevaient
des points quand on avait beaucoup trop
d'orthographe mais jamais qui rajoutait
de points si on est on était facile à
copier était parfaite pour d'autres
l'orthographe est toujours un handicap
là je travaille à la banque pour
l'écriture d'un mail je réfléchis je
sais pas trop comment accorder les mots
j'ai un peu de mal et ouais c'est
quelque chose qui pénalisé énormément à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui je vous constate
qu'en écrivant moi à la main on vient
nul en orthographe
un niveau plus que moyen en orthographe
qui se retrouve dès l'école dans les
dictées de CM2 en 1997 10,7 faut en
moyenne contre 19,4 l'an dernier des
fautes qui se retrouvent dans les copies
du baccalauréat alors pour le ministère
une solution les sanctionner dans la
note finale une pénalisation qui fait
réagir les syndicats d'enseignants en
fait si on ne fait que pénaliser que
noter en réalité on ne construit pas
quel genre ancien champion olympique
français de saut à la perche c'est
depuis reconverti dans la voile
[Musique]
j'en sais rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jouer encore au foot moi je suis beau
pas forcément être beau je crois que au
fil du temps je commence femme dire
c'est pas normal de s'intéresser à des
gens qui se passent un ballon avec les
pieds vous êtes pied gauche ou pied
droit pied droit tant mieux
[Applaudissements]
quand vous regardez cnews qu'on vous
regardez ce qu'est devenu Europe 1
quand vous regardez cet ensemble là la
conclusion s'impose JDD enfin pardon
Europe 1 c'est news d'extrême droite
ce sont des publications c'est news
c'est très clairement l'exemple
aucun doute moi je suis vous savez donc
je considère je considère que lutter
contre l'extrême droite c'est une
priorité ça peut se faire de toutes les
manières possibles quand j'étais enfant
je voulais être curé et puis après j'ai
voulu être comédien sous parce que je
pensais que j'avais un talent j'ai
raconté l'histoire un jour à pire Arditi
qui a beaucoup ri et puis après j'aurais
aimé être médecin et rien ne s'est fait
mais finalement je suis devenu et pour
mon bonheur à moi cuisinier mais le
cuisinier réunit il a quelque chose du
curé du comédien et du médecin voilà le
résultat de ce police bashing permanent
elle a reçu cette lettre salut fliquette
tu vas avoir de la visite les voitures
brûles et les fenêtres explosent
j'espère que l'assassin d'un enfant va
prendre 20 ans c'est sale bâtard
pardonnez-moi de l'expression de flics
pléonasme ton adresse va être divulguée
à cab voilà ce que vivent vos frères
d'armes sur le terrain depuis maintenant
deux semaines mais ça dure depuis très
longtemps centre deux morceaux iliège
l'un s'est lancé dans un lomologue
imaginons ce que pourrait ce qu'on
pourrait faire à Emmanuel Macron elle le
voyait accroché à 20 mètres du sol comme
une pineata géante et tous ici nous
aurions d'énormes battes avec des clous
et on aurait tous notre pâte avec nos
petits clous et dans un feu de Bengale
de joie de servir et de sang on le
foutrait à terme et gentiment tu vois
[Musique]
appelle au meurtre du président de la
République de la révolution s'est créé
ici on se rappellera de nous à la fille
fille de qui fait tout un scandale
j'avoue que
c'est un peu comme Marion Cotillard qui
sur son yacht qui nous parle de la
planète quoi il y a quelque chose quand
même de toujours un peu dérangeant à
aller dans une telle outrance on s'en
prendre au président de la République on
a l'impression que sa nouvelle façon de
choquer le bourgeois de faire parler de
soi autrement que par son œuvre ou sa
musique que ce que vache parce qu'il y a
des chansons qui restent il y a des
poèmes qui restent il y a des écrits qui
restent mais les provocations comme
celle-là sont sans doute inutiles et
inefficaces moussons matrières en Inde
au moins 15 personnes sont mortes après
d'importants glissement de terrain et
des inondations records dans le nord du
pays au plus de 700 route ont été
coupées la capitale du Delhi n'avait pas
vu autant de pluie dans une même journée
depuis 40 ans le bilan entouré encore
s'alourdir des plus torrentielles sont
encore attendus dans les prochains jours
[Musique]